welcome back to city skylines today I
want to tackle what is for me at least
by far one of the biggest criticisms
that I have on the city which is it's
simply her lack of bodies of water
just small ditches and ponds not
necessarily the rivers or canals there's
plenty of them to go around in this map
but just a small interaction with water
that you so commonly find in
neighborhoods in the Netherlands is
something which I have very much missed
out on in this city so far and assuming
that I do in a try more so this episode
will sort of be my first step toward
that although I do have to say I'm not
entirely going for these small ditches
and ponds that you usually find which
has everything to do with the reasons
why so far in the city I haven't really
used any sort of water interaction in
neighborhoods it's just because the
terraforming tools are quite clunky and
the water in this game can just be is so
unpredictable at times and it just
doesn't feel really made for these very
small ditches and ponds that you
commonly find in neighborhoods with
which sort of run through the
neighborhoods behind houses and along
side streets in a way that I find is
near impossible to actually do in this
in city skylines but it's still
something I really wish to try and yeah
this will sort of be a first step
basically what I want to do and that is
after I am done flooding my city over
here is to add a neighborhood which even
though it doesn't have these small
separate ditches and ponds has some
water interaction in the shape of
drawing water from the river and using
them for some canals sort of running
through the middle of this neighborhood
it's very much inspired by a somewhat
recent it's not that recent any more
housing project near Rotterdam called
Connie cylinder which probably barely
anyone knows what I'm talking about in
this case so I'll try to briefly explain
what the idea is behind this it sort of
draws not just the basic shape
inspiration from set neighborhood but
it's a housing project which draw some
canals and a lot of water interaction
from a nearby lake
and I really figured I could to a
similar thing in this case and draw some
water from the river in which case I
don't have to mess with having to work
too precisely with the terraforming
tools or water sources I could just draw
water from the river itself and use that
for canals or it should be a little bit
easier and better to do than just trying
to make these small ditches which I
really fear eventually just doesn't work
because they're too small and water
level is generally also too high it's
actually make it work in this game the
general makeup of this neighborhood is
going to be around one sort of
centerpiece the main square inside that
half circle will be aware I want to add
some larger apartments but also some
restaurants and some shops which is
which sort of should function as a small
city center for this little suburb and
then everything around it will just
exist out of islands literally and
figuratively that's have these row
houses on them and which connects to
that center piece and from that to the
outside world as well and much of the
shapes will be very much like the houses
that I've done in the last couple of
episodes really still playing with a
grid-like pattern but as you can see
sometimes just removing some roads and
leaving some pedestrian paths or you
know playing with these shapes of the
grid a little bit so even though it's
slightly on the grid there are some
waves in the roads as well or sometimes
just straight diagonals there's no such
thing as a straight diagonal sometimes
just diagnosed running straight through
a grid to at least break it up a little
bit and make it not so boring but yeah
that is the basic makeup of this
neighborhood and something that I also
sort of want to talk about and this is
quite important since I really feel
what's a important realism aspects which
I haven't gotten in this city so far and
what is one of my main complaints as to
why I think it is so important to add
more water interaction and why I think
it's such a big problem that this
he doesn't have it is that realistically
there actually is a minimum safety
standard for a new touch road for new
touch neighborhood developments and as
I've said in the first episode of this
series is that Dutch people like to just
meander about something
eternally until they actually plan it so
while a neighborhood can be planned far
ahead and still needs a lot of
discussing and looking at it from all
different angles to actually make it
work eventually at some point in time
now one very important step in that is
that new neighborhoods must actually be
addressed in a way that they are safe
when it comes to water because the issue
is being the Netherlands and being below
sea level and even below the height of
your rivers is that you need some ways
to if it rains terribly to catch that
rain and until you can transport it
using those fancy windmills first things
like that you also need somewhere to
store it and this is where generally a
lot of the ditches and ponds in the
Netherlands come in since they're not
just there to make the entire
neighborhood look pretty and land value
pretty high but also because there needs
to be this way of getting rid or at
least storing your rainwater until you
can get rid of it it's very much like a
popular thing nowadays which is that
many cities have these squares which are
below like the street level of the rest
of the city so that when it rains those
squares can catch the rainwater sort of
store it's for a while become a little
lake and then when there's a drier
period they can get rid of that water
again and the entire city doesn't float
which is an excellent idea until the
rain goes away and it leaves that square
with green stuff and plants everywhere
but it's it's sort of that same idea of
trying to catch the water and store it
until someday that you can get it out
there and because of this water safety
then is quite important to the
Netherlands there are many things which
a new neighborhood does have to commit
to and I'm not entirely sure of what the
exact things are that they need to do in
order to get it water safe and
prove to by all the people who need to
approve neighborhood because before it
can be built and I'm definitely no
expert on this but one of the ways in
which this is very commonly and
importantly done is by having all of
these little ponds and ditches
everywhere just to be able to at least
catch and store rainwater and this is
why I also feel like a major limitation
of this city exists so far because quite
frankly the city just isn't or at least
major parts of this city probably just
aren't safe when it comes to touch water
rule and when it comes to touch water
rules and in real life maybe would have
flooded by now and that's a realism
aspect which sort of like in this city
and of course what it just looks nice as
well
but how that is in general why I want to
add more water in the future but so far
it's something which is really hard to
play with due to so many different
factors and this is especially true for
farmland so that's why I'm still not
adding any ditches around the farmlands
and just want to sort of keep the
pedestrian paths as stand-ins for future
perhaps stitches that I might add at
some point in the future it really just
feels to me at least like the water
tools in this game aren't entirely fits
for trying to make a touch City and
let's do something I have to play around
or at least work around I should say
before I can actually make it work
I guess it's I want to find some ways to
at least incorporate more water into the
city but it's really hard to do so it's
basically the basic message that I want
to get out there now something which i
think is also worth talking about aside
from the water management of the city I
think is the way that the traffic is
laid out over here and I feel the basic
idea really comes down to that this is a
series of little islands of row houses
and I'm not talking about the islands
inside the river but more in the traffic
perspective that even though all of
these row houses are placed in a very
grid like road pattern all of these
grids sort of form their own little
island
since there aren't interconnected with
any roads except just one road for each
little island of rowhouses that connects
them to the outside world and the rest
of this neighborhood and I feel this is
quite important since at least I feel
and realistically for a Dutch city you
want to avoid making any making it so
car centric and this is quite a common
critique I think of city skylines in
general but it's a very car-centric game
it's very much like made to make those
American grid like cities and that
really greatly contrasts with what touch
cities are all about which is among a
shared space and bricks on your road
also a lot less of the great like way of
building and in cities college is really
reflected by how you can only Zone
alongside roads and you really have
these asphalt roads everywhere and you
know even working within that I wanted
to at least minimize this very car
centric way of working with roads and so
really imitating the neighborhood stay
you often find in the Netherlands I
wanted to make these little islands of
grids so for example he live in one of
those houses in that curve over there
you're very close to the entrance of
this neighborhood and also the center
with the shops and stuff but as you can
see if your your car user then you first
sort of had to go into that entrance
area and use the one entrance Road into
that little grid of houses even though
it is so close to the entrance this way
of just having one little road or tulip
roads that connects to one specific grid
really sort of makes using a car a lot
less fun and handy in this area and so I
really want to battle the cars centrism
with not just the road layout like that
but one thing which is also quite
important is adding all of those little
shortcuts everywhere as you can see
there is that small road over there
which goes from the grid which I just
talked about with the houses outside the
curve there to the centre area and the
centre area also sort of connects all of
the sites with pedestrian roads and
making some pedestrian roads along side
the sides of these neighborhoods as well
just to make sure that you can
just about everywhere with little
shortcuts if you're a bike user or
pedestrian which car users can't use you
could say the same actually about this
diagonal which goes straight through
this grid something which I should
quickly talk about yeah I forgot to turn
off my I mean I forgot to turn on my
lute for this recording over here so
yeah this is actually the in-game lute
what was very funny actually I found was
that on that super ultra great wonderful
delicious glitch that I found where the
grass was just extended up until the sky
was really weird but I had my lutes
turned off for that video yet I still
got some questions about what lute I was
using well this is what the temperate
theme looks like it's actually pretty
good I just find that there's an
incredible amount of yellow in the lute
overall that I think without all of the
yellow shades it looks a lot more
realistic anyway that is grossly
off-topic I wanted to also add a small
score of it I think it's just sort of
shoved along the side there not too
happy about it's just sort of like oh I
still need to school I'll just put that
here I might want to tackle that in the
future and at least make that a little
less awkward I'm feeling I might want to
put it closer to the centre of this
neighborhood but for the time being this
is going to be the elementary school for
this neighborhood and also mention by
the way that just one elementary school
for this neighborhood is probably not
enough but that's something you should
also get back to in the future
overall though this is going to be the
final layouts of this neighborhood and
you can very clearly see those little
living islands with row houses and Hill
just on the water but also alongside the
sides where there's little or green
spaces but also rotla spaces between all
the neighborhoods which really make and
this is I think quite an important
points not just from probably my
ideology of building cities but also if
you're playing this game in general
having the fact that car users need to
take a longer route around a certain
area where pedestrians and cyclists can
just use these shortcuts which are
everywhere just makes traffic a lot
better and in this case in any case
makes it a lot more touch just to have
those bicycle lanes just about
everywhere which cut through
neighborhoods and things like that so
yeah just a word of advice I suppose if
you're building a Dutch city or any type
of themed city out there it really can
be a lot of fun but also quite handy to
sort of split up your residential areas
into little islands and keep some green
spaces in between them and make sure not
to connect them with too many roads
while still adding all of these little
shortcuts for pedestrians and cyclists
everywhere only thing which I think I
can really criticize about this general
setup is that there's no real idea of
mixed zoning and this is something which
you can very much also critique the
American suburbs for is that are just
endless areas of places to live but you
don't really work or shop or entertain
yourself much here and you're gonna move
elsewhere for all of that and I tried to
at least minimize this a little bit over
here by having the more mixed-use parts
in the middle of this neighborhood just
so that people don't have to move too
far to at least go to that basic needs
like going to a supermarket or going to
a small restaurant or a snack corner
shop no idea what now should exactly be
but still there is quite a lack of
mixtone you could say in this type of
making neighborhoods I wanted to have a
small body of water over you just to
also have the
on this side and really thought it would
be so much better than just an empty
patch of grass and especially it would
have been better than just a forest over
there because that would it probably
made no sense in the context of this
being the Netherlands but as you could
see it was still a bit of a struggle to
get the water level to be exactly where
I won in it and accidentally flooded
this area again a couple of times
shouldn't be too bad people can handle
it it is the Netherlands after all so
there's loads of emergency plans for
that but it's it's something which I I
should do probably that was actually
this person I think who I don't know
when I ever heard that but this person
who said that like weed is legal in the
Netherlands so that everybody can get
high enough to avoid getting drowned by
the sea or which should find quite El
arias actually I got my voice isn't
entirely great and yes but yeah actually
I found that I have had many comments
about some you're making a Dutch city I
just make sure you have the encourage
bike policy and legalize weed and and
that's something which should make your
city realistically Dutch and those are
two things which I sort of still need to
do actually speaking at this point in
time I have already encouraged biking
but I'm not sure about the weird parts
because realistically I'm not sure if I
should actually do it anyway that is
extremely off-topic I wanted to add a
bit of foliage over here and I said I
actually think I could work with more
foliage especially given how the trees
have gotten an updates in snowfall or
which I am not entirely happy about
there's loads of awesome things in the
new updates but the trees which I've
used throughout the city which is that
tree which you can see in the top left
corner which sort of arches around the
stadium which is now invisible because
it has a terrible LOD is a non-existent
LOD is a tree which got sort of done
skilled in the new updates it doesn't
have as many leaves anymore it's not as
dense as it was anymore so I'll
definitely come back to the foliage in
the future but yeah as I was saying the
foliage I think is still quite very
sparse in this city overall and it's
something which I might in the future at
some point say hey I'll just do a
foliage episode
and add more detail and make it a bit
more dense especially in some areas
where I don't quite have any three lines
yet and so that is this episode which I
might do in a future but yeah I keep in
mind that the foliage at least in many
parts of the city are still a bit
work-in-progress and more of the overall
idea than 100% what I want to go with
and now I just want to sort of close
this off as I was just talking about
snowfall by talking about the elephant
in the room over here lost episode in
the description but also in the comment
section I've sort of thrown it fits
around snowfall and I feel really bad
about this in hindsight shouldn't have
done it
I should also stop saying the word in
hindsight so often it's two words that
doesn't matter
I the issue was basically for anybody
who missed it last episode I was pretty
angry because my city couldn't load
anymore and actually spend my entire
Saturday trying to get it to work to no
avail
but I'm really happy to at least be able
to say that I did get it back it was
eventually fine Road Heights which
screwed things over and with finding the
new updates of fine Road Heights that
the author brought out which was very
much requested I think the city works
again albeit I also need to leave
traffic plus plus in ghost mode which
leaves me with terribly raped AI for
traffic among other problems but yeah
the city is working again I'll keep this
going for quite a while I'm not entirely
sure how yet how long I'll keep this
city going for because I have some other
plans as well but yeah just as a small
thoughts I got the city to work again I
will be playing with perhaps some extra
editions for his from snowfall at least
the new terrain themes of course even
though that was added in the free patch
but yeah something to keep in mind also
I just wanted to just have this small
plaza over here just to provide a small
at least cozy atmospheric little city
center over here despite it's still
being so modern and recently develops I
really felt that I still at least wanted
to make it a bit atmospheric protip by
the way if you have any sort of cold
looking area with loads of concrete and
modern
buildings and a ton of foliage should
help alleviate that alien alienating
effective endless concrete because lots
of foliage cried quite frankly just
makes anything look very atmospheric and
inviting anyway that is about it for the
time lapse for today but this incredibly
already overly long video still has one
real-time parts so I'm gonna hand it
over to my past real time self here
alright now this episode is already
overly long but I just wanted to quickly
show off in greater detail and less
speed what this area actually looks like
and maybe also talk a bit about the
future and what I'm planning to do in
the near future but yeah basically it's
very similar to the houses that I've had
so far and I should stop using the half
circles because you do see them quite
often in road layouts but this is
getting a little bit ridiculous so this
should be the most of that but over here
I really wanted to have it since I
wanted to have that small centre with
flat blocks and shops and some
restaurants and stuff like that but yeah
it's quite similar as I said to all the
other neighborhoods
I just went overboard with the foliage I
think and I tried to some new lampposts
a little bit more modern I think they
came out today they're called the white
bendy things and I kind of liked them
I'm still not 100% sure about them since
you do often see lampposts that are more
ambani and have these wide curves in
newer neighborhoods but they would have
a separate lamp installed and these are
just white bandy lamps themselves so I
might still change that maybe some nude
lamps who will come out in the future
but I do kind of like them and in
general I think the area is quite a
modern Dutch look to it this way and
yeah that's pretty much that over there
now over here is a basketball field
where I don't actually know if there are
any separate basketball posts I was
trying to find them but I couldn't
really find them and I already had this
thing placed so I might want to still
look into that because this is a bit of
a weird thing at the moment but the
other thing which I'm definitely most
happy about in this area is the little
plaza in the middle of it I just wanted
to make sure that I had a small Center
in the middle of this suburb you know
the way you could at least shop but that
would also
have a bit of a cozy feeling to it and
at least sort of feel like a small city
centre and that's why I also wanted to
decorate it quite a lot and add some
restaurants to it and that's pretty much
what this is like and of course there's
a circle around it because I couldn't
stop myself from doing that here's the
elementary school I might still get a
small industrial zone around here
especially since and this is one of my
biggest issues we're trying to get this
area to actually work I don't have
enough goods to sell at these things
which is weird because well I have the
train cargo train terminal over here and
that is pretty close to this so I
figured they would be able to actually
get some goods out of other cities to
sell over here but apparently I can't
so even though this looks pretty nice at
the moment these buildings will soon be
removed again because they can't sell
stuff and that's an issue I still need
to fix I suppose it's not so big of an
issue another issue is also that the
water level is a little bit low like you
can see this over here and I'd rather
have the water just above this little
thing or at least a little bit higher
than it is at the moment and the thing
with that is that I don't think I just
want to place another water source and
raise the level of the water that way
because that means that this area will
most likely flood so that's something I
still need to look into but yeah in the
future I plan on getting the University
campus over here which should be one
large straight road but I also want to
work with a bit of a plaza and make it
more of a pedestrian focused University
than just having a road system sort of
just want to tuck the roads in the back
and keep it mostly pedestrian and
decorated a little bit and I might want
to remove the stadium in the future I
don't really like it so far it's very
low poly especially if you zoom out the
LOD is pretty bad on that one
and it's also a bit too long I think
plus it's it's FC Barcelona that's way
too obvious so yeah if I ever find a
better Stadium that actually works and
has about the same size then I may very
well get a different football stadium
over here but yeah that's it's for today
pretty much oh maybe I should get a
couple more
of kind of going through this I kind of
like this street actually now I do have
to say about this as much as I like the
Swedish houses and as much as I think
they do follow the same style that you
often see in modern Dutch neighborhoods
for the next couple of neighborhoods
that I'll be building I kind of want to
refrain from the using them as much he
says you can kind of see these areas
which have used the Swedish houses for
are starting to become a little bit
similar and if I ever want to well if I
am ever going to which I will most
likely do remove this area and
completely redo it I might want to work
a little bit more with the English
houses as well as the English detached
houses that I still have lying around
but yeah that's something for the future
also so me for the future is the city
center which is right now it's just like
a gaping hole in the middle of the city
and it is quite painful to look at so
that's something I want to do in the
future but first the university
definitely anyway thanks for watching
this way to long video and see you next
time
oh no anyway I was